Eric Williams and Latvia
Washington McGee join me now.
Thank you so much for being with us.
So what happened when you crossed over?
We turned down this little side road
because we've gone
see if that led us to the destination
and we were going to turn around.
We heard a car beat the horn
and pulled around us.
The nail was in the back.
He said, Don't stop.
He saw a gun.
We drove through a few street corners
until we got back on the main street.
And that's when
a gang of shooting started.
Then they are and shot.
He they jumped out to run,
and they were gunned down.
There was a time when they'll be
in a car window
with a little gun
and probably a nine millimeter.
Mm hmm.
And I jumped out of the driver's side.
And when I jumped out
on the driver's side,
that's when I was shot
and both legs loose on the wire.
For maybe like 10 minutes
before they took everything from us.
And I guess
whoever told them to just go ahead
and bring us with them.
That's when they loaded us
on the back of the truck.
And your two friends.
Were they still alive that point?
They were alive at a point.
I couldn't see he because he was light
behind me,
but I could see these in their back.
He was hit two times, and big chunks of
meat was gone down.
And then
we were
all probably ten, 15 more minutes.
And we got to the spot
where they was taking us.
The investigator interrogated us more
And that's one shot. He's ahead.
I love y'all.
And I'm gone.
And he died right there.
Those are his truck.
Yeah. That he loved us.
And he was gone.
That was the last thing
he say.
And that was in the back of the pickup,
sir.
Were you able to say anything to him or
told him I was sorry?
So you finally arrive
at this destination.
What was it?
It was a it was a house
with a lot of things.
Goods
put in El Diablo, man.
His red plastic man.
They put mass on.
Yeah, I was put in the gun,
and still I had
telling us not to look up things
like that.
Had you gotten
any kind of medical treatment?
The cartel took us to a clinic after
we left from the spot
where they was questioned.
And so they told us they was like,
I guess
after they kept asking us
and our questions,
that answers never change.
They said, Well, we're going to.
We're going to get you some help.
What kind of treatment did they give you?
They put my
leg on a two-by-four
and then they stitched it up
they just stitched it up.
Right.
Did they give you no pain medicine
or nothing?
They just stood up
and it might have not even been.
Later the same day,
all the stitches burst out
Did they check to see
if the bullet was still inside
or anything like that?
No, sir.
After they staged it,
they took some light I guess goes
and they put the toolbar
floorboard under there
and they was wrapping it around
like that.
And I was telling them
the tool by the two-by-four
was hitting me in the back of my leg
and it was killing me.
So they took away the Two-by-four.
What about Z del me?
I was in a room together
and he was fighting
for his life and
they do know
they didn't do anything to treat him.
Was he conscious?
Were you able to talk to him?
Yeah.
Talk to him the whole time.
What do you say in a situation like that?
I just told him I'm sorry
because I asked him to come with me.
You like?
It's okay. I'm your brother.
I'm supposed to be there for you.
I love you.
And is that where he died?
They talked at the heated fights along
they was like
they were taken to the hospital.
Then they came back, like,
maybe an hour later
and was like he was dead.
So all this time, I'm there.
There's guys with guns around you
guarding, right?
They was like, they.
We had to stay there for
them to investigate us. And
different things.
And like,
one of them was sitting a chair, like,
where he seemed to,
and he was looking
at something on his phone.
And I can remember the sound of that day.
When it happened.
Like,
I could remember the gunshots, the noise.
And I heard it
and I x and I said, excuse me.
Is that us?
And he said, Yes.
I say, can I see And he's like, Hold on.
And he turned the phone around
and saw the video of us being kidnaped
and stuff like that.
The one of the gunmen
actually showed you the video
that we've all seen of you
being kidnaped on the street
That's surreal.
I mean, what did that.
What was that like? I just started crying
like I'm never going home.
Did in any way help you to know
that this video was out there,
that people at least knew it?
So I thought
maybe he was just out in Mexico.
I didn't know that in the United States.
Right.
So I felt a little better
as I just didn't know
our families knew
anything that happened to us.
Your you're a woman in custody with
cartel gunmen.
Were they threatening to you
in violence and sexual violence?
I mean, yeah, they said all this stuff
all the they did.
They try and make us
have sex with each other.
But it was brothers, brother and sister
that she was pregnant.
Wait a minute.
They tried to make
you have sex with each other.
What did they say to you?
They was like, what are y'all?
We said, brothers and sisters,
and they was like,
have sex with each other.
Like, no, these are my brothers.
I'm pregnant.